Let's walk through the tasks
you need to accomplish to take
GIFMaker to the next level.
You want to be able to save a GIF and
display it in a collection.
So you'll need to implement
a collection view.
You want the user to be able to view the
details of each GIF in the collection.
So you'll also need to set
up a detail view controller.
You want to be able to persist GIFs,
which we'll do with NSKeyedArchiver.
And then in the end, you'll want
to add some finishing touches,
including styling, and
the first time user experience.
Let's start by focusing in
on the first two tasks.
Save a GIF and
view GIFs in a collection.
In order to save a GIF, you'll need to
create the SavedGifsViewController and
configure the
PreviewViewControllerDelegate.
In order to view GIFs in a collection,
you'll need to implement the necessary
protocols, starting with the
CollectionViewDatasource protocol and
the CollectionViewFlowLayout protocol.
You'll also need to create a custom
class for the CollectionViewCell.
Let's get started by creating
the SavedGifsViewController.